It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务发展迅速。为了让花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢忙碌，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为 35 美元/月。这绝对是一个不会常有的超值优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需加收税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Life is full of situations that try our patients. You're late for work and the driver in front of you is going 15 miles below the speed limit. Your preschooler insists on putting on her own shoes and it's taking 10 minutes per foot. You had an interview for your dream job weeks ago and you're waiting with increasing anxiety to hear back from the company. In each of these situations, you try to remain calm, but you can feel your stress level rising. philosophers and religious leaders have long extolled the virtue of patients. And in more recent years, psychologists have found that patients is good for our mental and even
在网络高负荷使用期间，Google Fi Wireless 不会遭遇数据流量降速。生活充满了考验我们耐心的时刻。你上班迟到了，而前面司机的车速比限速低了整整 15 英里。你的学龄前儿童坚持要自己穿鞋，并且每只脚都要花上 10 分钟。你几周前参加了你梦寐以求的工作面试，正怀着日益加剧的焦虑等待公司的回复。在每一种这样的情况下，你都试图保持冷静，但你能感觉到自己的压力水平在上升。哲学家和宗教领袖长期以来一直赞美耐心的美德。而在近年来，心理学家发现耐心对我们的心理乃至
our physical health, but it's not easy to achieve. So why is patients so hard to come by? Has modern life and modern technology made us less patient? Is it possible to become a more patient person? And if you want to do so, what are the best strategies? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
身体健康都有益，但这并非易事。那么，为什么耐心这么难得呢？现代生活和现代科技是否让我们变得更加缺乏耐心了？我们有可能成为一个更有耐心的人吗？如果你想做到这一点，最好的策略是什么？欢迎收听《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
My guest today is Dr. Sarah Schnitker, a professor of psychology and neuroscience at Baylor University, where she studies patients and other virtues, including self-control, gratitude, and generosity. She's especially interested in the role of spirituality and religion in virtue formation. Dr. Schnitker has published more than 100 peer-reviewed articles, and her work has been covered in mainstream media outlets, including the New York Times, CNN, and Time Magazine. Dr. Schnitker, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. It's wonderful to be here. Most people know what the word patience means, but I'm curious how you define it in your work.
我今天的嘉宾是贝勒大学心理学和神经科学教授莎拉·施尼特克博士，她在那里研究耐心和其他美德，包括自我控制、感恩和慷慨。她对灵性和宗教在美德形成中的作用特别感兴趣。施尼特克博士已发表了 100 多篇同行评审文章，她的工作已被《纽约时报》、《CNN》和《时代周刊》等主流媒体报道。施尼特克博士，非常感谢你今天能来。非常感谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。大多数人都知道“耐心”这个词的意思，但我很好奇你在工作中是如何定义它的。
Is it close to the way we think about it colloquially? I think it is pretty similar, and, you know, I think it's always interesting when we define that. the word to actually look at the Latin root. It actually means to suffer. And so for many of us, when we have to be patient, we feel like we are suffering. But the way we define it in psychology is that ability to remain calm and wait calmly in the face of frustration, adversity, or suffering. And so we all encounter people, events, kind of hardships in our daily lives that require us to wait and to put on the brakes a little bit. And that can be really difficult. But if people who are patient are able to do that and still remain calm and settled and not become
这和我们日常思考它的方式接近吗？我认为挺相似的，你知道，我觉得当我们定义这个词时，去看看它的拉丁语词根总是很有趣。它实际上意味着“承受”。因此，对我们许多人来说，当我们必须保持耐心时，我们觉得自己正在承受痛苦。但在心理学中，我们将其定义为：在面对挫折、逆境或痛苦时，能够保持冷静并平静等待的能力。所以我们所有人都会在日常生活中遇到需要我们等待并稍微踩刹车的人、事件和各种艰难险阻。这可能会非常困难。但是，如果那些有耐心的人能够做到这一点，并且依然保持镇定和安详，而不会在
overwhelmed with emotion as they engage in that waiting. Why is patient such a hard thing for some of us to achieve? Are we hardwired to be impatient? Well, that is a great question. I mean, I think, you know, patience, we are often employing patients in pursuit of our goals. And we want to achieve either small goals of getting to work on time or big goals of raising a child who is the kind and generous person. And we often feel patient when we feel like something's blocking our goal pursuit and we want to get there faster. And so in some ways, we could say that impatience might have evolved evolutionarily to, push us forward and make us notice when we need to move forward in our goals. But oftentimes, it's useful to learn about what's going on from our emotions, but then it's often not very
参与这种等待时被情绪压倒。为什么耐心对我们中的一些人来说是一件如此难以实现的事情呢？我们天生就缺乏耐心吗？嗯，这是一个好问题。我的意思是，我认为，你知道，耐心，我们经常在追求目标时运用耐心。我们想要实现小目标，比如按时上班，或者实现大目标，比如把孩子抚养成一个善良慷慨的人。当我们觉得有什么东西阻碍了我们追求目标，而我们又想更快达到目标时，我们常常会感到不耐烦。所以在某些方面，我们可以说不耐烦可能是通过进化发展而来的，用以推动我们前进，让我们注意到什么时候需要在目标上向前迈进。但通常情况下，了解我们的情绪正在发生什么是有用的，但随后
helpful to kind of stay in this state of impatience and be overwhelmed with emotion. And so having the capacity to regulate that impatience and be able to still pursue your goal, but in a more calm manner is really going to be kind of adaptive for us, especially in the modern air, where we aren't necessarily a goal for the day is not to find enough food so I can eat tonight. Some people deal with that, but many people kind of in Western industrialized context, right, that patients that maybe evolved for really life and death scenarios is being transferred over to other things that are not as life and death. and maybe we don't need as much of a strong impatient reaction to.
一直停留在这种不耐烦的状态中并被情绪压倒往往并无益处。因此，具备调节这种不耐烦的能力，并能够继续追求你的目标，但以一种更平静的方式，对我们来说确实具有适应性意义，尤其是在现代社会中——在这里我们不一定每天的目标都是为了找到足够的食物来支撑今晚的进食。有些人确实需要应对这种情况，但许多处于西方工业化背景中的人，你知道，那种可能为生死攸关的场景进化而来的耐心，正被转移到其他并不那么生死攸关的事情上，或许我们不需要对此产生那么强烈的缺乏耐心的反应。
When do we first learn the concept of patience? Did we discover the answer through Walter Mitchell's famous marshmallow experiments? Well, you know, we first learned, I mean, in psychology, I would say, really became popularized then. But the idea of patience is really an ancient concept. And philosophers and theologians have been talking about patience for millennia. and have recognized it as really a perennial human problem. But things do not go as fast as we want. We are not able to kind of get past our suffering.
我们是什么时候第一次学会“耐心”这个概念的？我们是通过沃尔特·米歇尔著名的棉花糖实验发现答案的吗？嗯，你知道，我们第一次学会——我的意思是，在心理学中，可以说它真的是从那时开始普及的。但耐心的理念其实是一个古老的概念。哲学家和神学家几千年来一直在讨论耐心，并承认它确实是一个长久以来存在的人类问题。事情并不会像我们希望的那样进展那么快。我们无法轻易摆脱我们的痛苦。
And so finding ways to wait and suffer with excellence is actually a thing a lot of philosophers talk about in virtue ethics. And so it's been fun in psychology to come to this conversation a little bit later, but with our new methods of using scientific inquiry. So just to reconstitute the question, is there an age in development that we learn we begin to understand what patients is and how to exercise it? We don't have for certain when patients itself develops, but we see immediately for an infant they experience waiting, right? That caregivers are not instantly responsive. We try to be responsive when we're a caregiver, but sometimes that baby has to wait for the bottle of milk to get wet.
因此，寻找以卓越的方式等待和承受痛苦的方法，实际上是美德伦理学中许多哲学家讨论的事情。因此，心理学能稍晚一点加入这场对话，并带着我们使用科学探究的新方法，是一件很有趣的事。为了重新阐述这个问题，在发育过程中，是否存在一个年龄，让我们开始理解什么是耐心以及如何行使耐心？我们无法确定耐心本身是在什么时候发展的，但我们从婴儿身上立刻就能看到他们会经历等待，对吧？照顾者并非即时响应。作为照顾者，我们努力做到响应，但有时那个婴儿必须等待一瓶奶被温热。
warmed up. But you see when children start to get more of a theory of mind, kind of toddler years, they then start to maybe understand that they want something now. Someone else doesn't want them to have that thing now and they have to wait. And so you see in young children pretty early that they have impatience. They don't want to wait. And any parent of a toddler can say this is something I'm talking to them about regularly. And you're like, okay, good, you get to practice your patience today. Right, we see that start to emerge, but I think it's really an adolescence where people have this capacity to really intentionally cultivate the virtue of patience and to think about kind of when is it wise to be patient? When is it not
但你可以看到，当儿童开始具备更多的心智理论时——大致在幼儿时期——他们随后可能会开始明白，他们现在就想要某样东西，而别人不想让他们现在就拥有那样的东西，他们必须等待。因此，你在幼儿身上很早就看到他们缺乏耐心。他们不想等待。任何照顾幼儿的父母都会说，这是我经常和他们谈论的事情。你会想：好吧，太好了，你今天可以练习你的耐性了。对，我们看到这种特质开始显露出来，但我认为真正到了青春期，人们才具备这种能力，去真正刻意地培养耐心的美德，去思考——什么时候明智地保持耐心？什么时候不明智？
wise? When should I actually allow myself to be upset if something appropriately to the situation? And so what we see start in early childhood kind of comes into full maturity in adolescence and young adulthood. In your work, you talk about three different kinds of patients, interpersonal life hardship and daily hassles. Tell us what each of those concepts mean. Interpersonal patience, as the name sounds, is about being patient with other people. And I think this might not be the first thing that comes to mind for many people. people in the United States at least. We often think of patients, traffic, getting stuck in lines, things like that.
什么时候我应该允许自己感到沮丧，如果某些事情符合当前情境的话？因此，我们看到始于幼儿期的特质在青春期和青年期走向完全成熟。在你的工作中，你谈到了三种不同类型的耐心：人际交往耐心、生活逆境耐心和日常琐事耐心。请告诉我们这些概念分别是什么意思。顾名思义，人际耐心就是对其他人保持耐心。我认为这可能不是美国很多人脑海中首先浮现的东西，至少在美国是这样。我们经常想到的耐心是交通、在队伍中卡壳之类的事情。
But we actually find that interpersonal patience is quite important and predicts a lot of well-being outcomes. And I think this makes a lot of sense. If you're able to be patient with your spouse, you're going to have a better marriage and better health. If as a parent, you have to be patient with your child as a coworker and to be patient with the perhaps annoying person next to my office, right? You know, there's lots of people in our lives who are slower than we would like
但我们实际上发现人际耐心非常重要，并且能预示许多幸福感的结果。我认为这非常合乎情理。如果你能对你的配偶保持耐心，你就会拥有更好的婚姻和更健康的身体。如果你作为父母，必须对你的孩子保持耐心；作为同事，必须对办公室隔壁那个可能有点烦人的人保持耐心，对吧？你知道，我们生活中有很多比我们希望的速度要慢的人，他们做着我们希望他们不要做的事情，而我们必须练习我们的耐心。我们还有关于日常琐事的耐心，这可能是更具刻板印象的场景：被困在红灯前，航班取消时在线上排队等待更改机票，对吧？这些考验我们耐心的日常琐事在等待中发生，但它们相对较小，并在一天当中不断累积。
who do things that we would prefer them not to do when we have to practice our patients. We also, with daily hassles patients, this might be the more stereotypic scenarios of getting stuck at a red light, waiting on hold to change your airline ticket when it's canceled, right? These things that are daily hassles that do test our patients as we wait, yet they're kind of smaller and build up across a day. And then the last type of patients of life hardships patients is kind of how we are patient with these very long-term goals that may or may not be resolved. So for instance, if someone has a long-term chronic health condition, they may not actually
然后是最后一种耐心——生活逆境的耐心，这有点像我们如何对那些可能会也可能不会得到解决的非常长期的目标保持耐心。例如，如果某人有长期的慢性健康状况，他们实际上可能并不认为自己会好转或者情况会有所改善，但他们在整个一生中应对该慢性健康状况时，仍然必须保持耐心。这意味着什么？这意味着能够等待？好吧，正如你知道的那样，这将是一段非常长的时间，你必须继续投入这种耐心。因此，这也可能包括诸如应对不公正的社会、应对生活中系统性种族主义的影响等事情，这需要耐心，但这不是你期望能立即结束的事情。因此，这为这种等待增添了另一层含义。你是否可能在其中一个领域擅长耐心，而在其他领域不擅长？例如，也许你在交通拥堵时抓狂，但你能应付生活中的重大挑战。这是常态，还是这三种耐心通常是相互关联的？
think they'll get better or that it will improve, but they still have to be patient as they deal with that chronic health condition across their life. And what does it mean to be able to wait? Well, as you know it's going to be a very long time, you have to continue to engage this patience. And so that could also include things of like dealing with an unjust society, dealing with the effects of systemic racism in your life, that it requires patience, but it's not something that you expect to have immediate end. And so that adds another layer to that weighting. Can you be good at patients in one of these domains but not the others? For example, maybe you get crazed in traffic, but you can handle life's big challenges. Is that the norm or do the three types of patients generally correlate together?
是的。我的意思是，我认为我们看到了变异性。因此，当我们观察这三种耐心时，平均而言，它们往往是相互关联的。因此，我们的一些研究也表明，可能存在这种普遍的耐心，它会产生影响——就像你可能拥有一般智力，但随后又有特定类型的智力一样。我们认为耐心可能也是这样的，存在这种普遍的情绪调节能力来等待。但是在那些不同的等待情境中存在区别。有些人可能真的很艰难地去等待其他人，但对生活逆境等事情却能应付自如。在我们的一些研究中，实际上我们做得更细化，询问人们他们在生活中追求的目标。
Yeah. I mean, I think we see in variability. So when we look at these three types of patients, on average, they tend to correlate with each other. So, and some of our research kind of has shown, too, that there might be this kind of general patience that influences kind of like you might have general intelligence, but then specific types of intelligence. We think that patients might be that way that there's this kind of general emotion regulatory capacity to wait. But there's distinctions in those different contexts of waiting. And some people might really struggle with waiting with other people. but be okay with life hardships and things like that. And what we actually show in some of our studies, some of our studies we actually do go more fine grain and ask people about the goals they're pursuing in life.
他们可能会说出这样的话：做一个好女儿，门门功课拿全A，每周去健身房锻炼多少次。然后我们针对每一个具体目标，询问他们付出了多少耐心，以及围绕对那个特定目标付出了多少耐心的条目。我们发现的是，存在着很大的变异性。
And they might say things like, be a good daughter, get straight A's, work out of the gym so many times a week. And then we ask them for each of those individual goals, how much patience, items around how much patience they exert for that specific goal. And what we found is there is, is a lot of variability.
因此，有些人有一个他们非常有耐心的目标，然后他们有一个他们完全没有耐心的目标，对吧，有很多情境特征可能会使这种耐心根据情况变得或多或少困难。我遇到过很多人，当我和人们谈论耐心时，这挺搞笑的，我无法告诉你人们谈论过多少次
So some people have a goal where they're very patient, and then they have a goal where they are not patient at all. And right, there's a lot of contextual features that might make that patience more or less difficult depending on the situation. I get a lot of people, it's kind of funny when I talk to people about patients, I can't tell you how many times people have talked
他们的的高尔夫球局，以及他们除了在打高尔夫球时之外，其他时候耐心都挺好。唯独在打高尔夫时，他们就是做不到。或者说，人们生活中有很多事情可能是特别困难的环境或游戏，真的考验他们的耐心。那么，请问你，我们把耐心当作一种美德来讨论，但它总是美德吗？还是有可能过于耐心？你如何判断什么时候一个情境需要耐心，什么时候又需要行动，这是否是任何人都会赞同的？不，我认为这是一个极好的问题。而且实际上，
about their golf game and how they are pretty good at patience except when they're playing golf. And then they just cannot. do it. Or like, people have lots of things in their lives that might be a particularly difficult circumstance or a game that really test their patience. Well, let me ask you, and we talk about patience as a virtue, but is it always a virtue or is it possible to be too patient? How do you judge when a situation requires patience and when it requires action, just in a way that anybody would agree? No, I think that's a great question. And actually,
真的非常重要，因为我认为多年来，你知道，有时耐心被武器化了。当某人希望另一个人被动时，他们可能会说：“嗯，你需要保持耐心。”在这种情况下，它可能就不是一种美德。因此，我认为在面对挫折和痛苦时能够平静等待的能力——这种能力，作为个人去做到这一点的能力——永远是一种美德。但无论是在特定时刻是否行使耐心，美德的一部分在于拥有智慧
really important because I think over the years, you know, sometimes patience is weaponized. And when someone wants someone else to be passive, they might say, well, you need to be patient. And in that case, it probably is not a virtue. And so I would argue that the capacity to wait calmly in the face of frustration and suffering, that capacity, the ability to do it as an individual, is a virtue always. But whether or not exercising patients in a particular moment, part of the virtue is having the wisdom
去知道这究竟是保持耐心的正确时刻，还是应该展现另一种能力或美德，比如勇气——它能帮助你在面对恐惧时采取行动。因此，我们在追求目标时运用我们的耐心。有时需要的是等待。如果那是明智的做法，拥有等待的能力可以帮助你做到这一点。
to know whether this is the right moment for patience or for another capacity or virtue like courage, for instance, which helps you act in the face of fear. And so we're using our patience in pursuit of goals. Sometimes what's needed is to wait. And having the capacity to wait helps you be able to do that if that is the wise thing to do.
但有时我们也需要采取行动，做出大胆的举动并向前迈进。而我认为，作为美德的耐心——作为我们拥有的这种特质、这种倾向——它给予你的正是刚好足够的空间来保持冷静，从而让你能够决定是采取行动还是继续等待。而如果你不具备那种倾向和能力，不具备耐心的技巧，那么你可能只会随波逐流于你的情绪。所以我很喜欢给出的一个例子是，比如说，对抗职场中的性别歧视，对吧？你知道，作为一个女性，有时我会遇到涉及性别歧视的情况。有时明智的做法是大声说出来，去借助
But sometimes we also need to act and take bold moves and move forward. And I think the thing that patience as a virtue, kind of as this trait, this disposition that we have, is it gives you just enough space to remain calm so you can decide if you're going to act or to wait. whereas if you don't have that disposition and that capacity, that skill of patience, then you might just be buffeted around by your emotions. And so an example I love to give is kind of, let's say, working against sexism in the workplace, for instance, right? You know, as a woman, sometimes I encounter a situation that involves sexism. And sometimes the wise thing to do is to speak up to pull upon.
我在那种能力下的勇气作为美德，并做点什么。而在其他时候，那并不是正确的时刻。事实上，在这种时刻保持安静并保持冷静才是正确的事情。我需要我的耐心来帮助我做到这一点。并且去理解，如果我的目标是创建一个公平、包容的工作场所，那么我既需要耐心也需要勇气来把我带到那里。这样我就能很好地应对各种情况，
on my courage as a virtue in that capacity and to do something. Other times, it's not the right moment. And that actually being quiet and just remaining calm in this moment is the right thing to do. And I need my patience to help me do that. And understanding, like, if my goal is to create an equitable, inclusive workplace, then I need to have both patience and courage to get me there. And that way I can navigate situations well.
而不只是被我的愤怒、恐惧所驱使，对吧？——我有能力以富有成效的方式调节我的情绪，为了我自己和他人好。长期来看，耐心和不耐机会对我们的身体产生什么影响？关于它是否是一种区别于其他负面情绪的独立负面情绪，外界有一些讨论。我的同事凯特·斯威尼认为它是，而且我认为是以一种非常令人信服的方式。至于不耐烦，你知道，我们还没有关于它的长期研究，因为没有人单独研究过它，但我们确实知道其他负面情绪，如愤怒、易怒。
and not just be driven by my anger or by my fear or by my, right, that I have the capacity to regulate my emotions in a productive manner for the good of myself and others. What do patients and impatience do to our bodies over the long term? There's a little bit of discussion out there of whether it's a discrete negative emotion, different from other negative emotions. My colleague Kate Sweeney, she argues that it is, and I think in a pretty convincing way. And in patients, you know, we don't have research on it long term yet because no one studied it discreetly, but we do know other negative emotions like anger, irritability.
如果我们每天的生活中持续感受到它们，这些情绪就会对我们的系统造成损害。因此它会导致心血管问题，导致许多慢性健康状况，这些状况根植于我们对压力的持续负面情绪反应中。因此我们发现，当人们更有耐心时，这可能会起到缓冲作用，使他们能够进行调节并继续追求生活中的重要目标，但不会像不具备这种能力时那样付出相同的生理代价，他们不会有那么多折磨他们的负面情绪。我们将进行短暂的休息。回来后，我将与施尼特克博士讨论如何在日常生活中变得更有耐心。
These tax our system if we are feeling them consistently in daily life. And so it can lead to cardiovascular problems, lead to a lot of chronic health conditions, have roots in kind of persistent negative emotions in reaction to us. stress. And so what we found is that when people are more patient, that it might buffer against that, that they're able to regulate and be able to maintain their pursuit of the important goals in their life, but not have the same cost physiologically as they have, they don't have as many negative emotions that are taxing them. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk to Dr. Schnicker about how to become more patient in your everyday life.
如果我们日常生活中经常感受到这些情绪，它们就会对我们的身体系统造成负担。这会导致心血管问题，引发许多慢性健康问题，其根源在于我们对压力做出的持续消极情绪反应。因此，我们发现当人们更有耐心时，它可能会起到缓冲作用，使他们能够调节情绪并继续追求生活中的重要目标，同时不会产生与以往相同的生理代价，也不会承受那么多对其造成负担的消极情绪。我们将稍作休息。回来后，我将与施尼克尔博士探讨如何在日常生活中变得更有耐心。
Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special buy for only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. Lost supplies last. Priced invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply.
家得宝（The Home Depot）现已推出阵亡将士纪念日促销活动，您的夏日狂欢就此开始。燃起您的夏日烧烤热情，下一代四火眼燃气烧烤炉特价仅需 199 美元，更有汉普顿湾西格罗夫七件套户外餐桌椅仅售 49 美元，让您尽享一整季的户外欢聚。今年阵亡将士纪念日，尽在家得宝享受超低价格保证。库存有限，售完即止。价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，适用相关免责条款。
See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room.
详情请参阅 Homedepot.com/pricematch。您之前说过这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路在哪。我们省了多少钱？够了。足够去放松一下了。或者您也可以预订希尔顿酒店。欢迎来到您的海景房。
Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get this stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. So for people who want to become more patient, which is probably many of our listeners, what advice do you have? What can you do to become more patient? You know, it's interesting. I think people do want to become more patient, but they also don't want to become more patient because
距离水边仅数步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开启。登录 Hilton.com 或使用希尔顿 App 预订，最高可省 20%，开启您期待的住宿体验。当您想要的是省心而非惊吓。住哪里至关重要。希尔顿，每一次入住。那么，对于那些想要变得更有耐心的人来说——这可能是我们听众中的绝大多数人——您有什么建议？我们可以做些什么来变得更有耐心？你知道，这很有趣。我认为人们确实想变得更有耐心，但他们同时又不想变得更有耐心，因为
they're afraid that to become more patient, I'll have to practice patience, which means I'll have to wait and suffer and all these things. I think I grew up in a religious community and like people would joke but actually say seriously like don't pray for patience. God will send you waiting and suffering. You don't want to pray for that. It'll mess up your life. It's kind of interesting because we're told to be patient, but there's this real fear. And so I think first understanding why it is you care about being patient is really important to motivate you. So understanding if you're thinking about kind of your life in general, in particular situation, so maybe I am struggling to be patient with my tween daughter. And connecting to my big picture,
他们担心要变得更有耐心，我就得练习耐心，这意味着我得去等待、去受苦以及经历所有这些事情。我觉得我在一个宗教社群中长大，人们会开玩笑，但实际上会非常严肃地说，千万不要祈求得到耐心。上帝会让你经历等待和痛苦。你可不想祈求那个。那会把你的生活弄得一团糟。这挺有意思的，因为我们被告知要保持耐心，但心底里又有着真实的恐惧。所以我想，首先理解你为什么在意自己是否富有耐心，对于激励自己非常重要。也就是说，你要弄清楚你是在考虑自己的一般生活，还是某个特定情境——比如，我可能正在努力对我的青春期女儿保持耐心。然后将其与我的宏大愿景联系起来，
why, of like, I view it as part of my job as a human being to, like, raise her to be a person of character in the world who contributes to society. And I do this even as a sacred activity that has immense meaning that when I think about that big picture purpose, then I can be motivated to say, okay, what are practices that will help me be more patient in my interactions with her? And that's when you get into the how.
也就是我为什么要把这看作是我作为一个人职责的一部分，去把她抚养成一个有品格、能够为社会做出贡献的人。我甚至把这当作一项具有巨大意义的神圣活动。当我考虑到那种宏大的目标时，我就会受到激励，去思考：好吧，有什么方法可以帮助我在与她的互动中更有耐心？然后你就会进入到“如何做到”的具体层面。
So how do I learn to regulate my emotions with her? And, right, we have a lot of strategies for emotion regulation that are evidence-based. And all of these are really useful and can be applied to patients. So like one of the best strategies is cognitive reappraisal, right? So thinking about the situation in a new way. There's lots of ways to do cognitive reappraisal.
那么，我该如何学会与她在一起时调节自己的情绪呢？没错，我们有很多基于证据的情绪调节策略。所有这些都非常有用，并且可以应用到耐心上。比如，最好的策略之一就是认知重评，对吧？也就是以一种新的方式看待局势。进行认知重评的方法有很多。
It could be a perspective taking of like, okay, how would I feel if I were nine and didn't have control and had just been told this mean thing and right? Like, you know, kind of entering the other person's perspective can really help with interpersonal patients. We also find, I think, you know, with reappraising how long things take, taking a slight historical perspective can be very quick way to be patient. So, you know, oh, why is this Wi-Fi so slow? And I'm like, actually, you know, just think about back to the 90s and you had dial-off
它可以是换位思考，比如：好吧，如果我九岁，没有自主控制权，刚被告知了这样一句刻薄的话，我会作何感想？对吧？像这样，你知道的，进入另一个人的视角确实大有助助于人际间的耐心。我们还发现，你知道的，通过重新评估事情需要花费多长时间，采取一种略微带有历史纵深感的视角，可以成为保持耐心的一种非常快捷的方法。所以，哎呀，为什么这个 Wi-Fi 这么慢？然后我就会想，其实，你知道的，回想一下90年代你还在用拨号上网的时候，
and it had like, you know, like just recalibrating our expectations through cognitive re-appraisal. There's lots of ways we can change what we're thinking. But what we also kind of some research has found recently is that a variety of emotion regulation strategies can be helpful. So even distraction. Even momentarily, sometimes suppression is the adaptive emotion regulation strategy in a particular moment. And recent work that's come out has shown that it's actually having a variety of strategies
它甚至还有那种，你知道的，就像通过认知重评来重新校准我们的期望。有很多方法可以改变我们的想法。但最近的一些研究也发现，各种各样的情绪调节策略都可以发挥作用。甚至连转移注意力也行。甚至在某些特定时刻，暂时进行压抑也是一种适应性的情绪调节策略。最近发表的研究表明，真正重要的是在你的情绪调节工具箱里
in your tool belt for regulating your emotion. that's really important and matching your strategy for patients to the situation. So sometimes it's like, you know what? I'm waiting on this thing. I'm just going to distract myself with a TV show. Right. But other times, especially perhaps with scenarios that have kind of existential import, like a chronic health condition or dealing with injustice or things that are more those life hardships or with other people, we might need more of that reappraisal to happen alongside. It can't be the suppression or distraction can't be the only strategy to work long term for being patient with those scenarios.
拥有多种策略，这非常重要，并且要将你的耐心策略与具体情境相匹配。所以有时候，这就像是：你知道吗？我在等这件事情。我打算看个电视节目来转移一下注意力。没错。但有时，尤其是对于那些带有生存意义的场景，比如慢性健康状况、面对不公，或者生活中更严峻的困境，或是与他人相处时，我们可能需要更多的重评机制与此并行。光靠压抑或分散注意力，是无法作为长期策略来对付那些场景并保持耐心的。
Sounds like some of this is to prevent yourself from ruminating on something that you have no control over. Exactly. Exactly. And that's when patient. And that's, I think, part of the reason patience is so hard for us in our cultural moment is, I mean, all humans like to have control and certainty. But I think in the modern era, we have, because of our technology, we have more illusions of control and have expectations
听起来，其中一部分是为了防止你对某些你无法控制的事情进行反刍思考。完全正确。完全正确。这就是当谈到耐心时……我认为这也是为什么在当今的文化氛围中，保持耐心对我们来说如此困难的部分原因。我的意思是，所有人类都喜欢控制感和确定性。但我认为在现代社会中，由于科技的发展，我们拥有了更多的控制错觉，并产生了
of control that are just unrealistic for our human to have with our bodies or our minds and that we have to often just wait on things, even though we think we shouldn't have to anymore. What if you have a spouse or a partner or even a kid whose patience meter is different from yours? How do you deal with those situations where someone's losing it because they have to wait? That's tough. I mean, it's hard enough to be patient for yourself, but for someone else. But I think with other people, and especially you see this with children and adolescents, oftentimes you are co-regulating with them.
对于控制的期望，而这种期望对于我们的身体或心智这种人类机体来说是不切实际的。尽管我们认为自己不该再去等待，但我们却常常不得不去等待。如果你有一个配偶、伴侣，甚至是孩子，他们的耐心阈值与你不同，你该如何处理那种有人因为必须等待而快要崩溃的情况呢？这很难。我的意思是，对自己保持耐心已经够难了，更不用说对别人了。但我认为，对于其他人，尤其是当你看到儿童和青少年时，通常你是在与他们共同调节情绪。
And even with a partner or spouse or coworker, you can start to verbally do some of that reappraisal and think about things differently or help kind of start that regulation. So for example, you know, amusement parks, so I think are like an experiment in patience. I want to do a study at one someday. Waiting in line. Waiting in line. For 10 seconds of fear. Exactly. What are we doing to ourselves? But it's interesting to see like what people do like with their children or with their partners as they do that. And right, do you get to talk about other things? Do you distract them? Do you say, okay, you know, at least it's better than that other ride that had the two hour wait, right? You can really start to see how strategies are used socially. And I think we can do that in our own lives. And, You have to be careful when you're helping someone else because what might be a strategy that works for you or what feels like the wise thing to do for you might not be the same for them.
甚至对于伴侣、配偶或同事，你也可以开始口头上进行一些认知重评，换个角度看待事物，或者帮助启动那种情绪调节的过程。举个例子，你知道的，游乐园就像是一场关于耐心的实验。我以后真想在那儿做个研究。排队。排队为了换取十秒钟的惊悚体验。 exatamente（没错）。我们到底在对自己做什么？但看到人们在排队时对自己孩子或伴侣做什么，这很有趣。对吧？你会去聊点别的吗？你会转移他们的注意力吗？你会说：好吧，你知道的，至少这比那个需要排两个小时队的过山车强多了，对吧？你真的能开始看到人们是如何在社交中运用这些策略的。我想我们在自己的生活中也可以这样做。而且，当你帮助别人时你必须小心，因为对你管用或者对你来说明智的做法，对他们来说可能并不适用。
So, for example, I mentioned Kate Sweeney earlier. She's done studies in the past on women waiting for breast biopsy results to find out if they have cancer, these other kind of really uncertain waiting scenarios. And you want to make sure that the support a partner provides is actually supportive and not kind of out of step with what the individual needs. And so I think it's always wise to also be checking in, especially if it's another adult you're waiting alongside to see what they need. And would it be helpful to go distract ourselves right now? Do you want to talk it through? Do you want to engage in problem solving? like we always often forget, we can just ask other people how we can help them. And I think that's a really wise step and lets the person get the kind of support they need.
所以，举个例子，我刚才提到过凯特·斯威尼（Kate Sweeney）。她过去曾对等待乳腺活检结果以确认是否患有癌症的女性进行过研究，这些是其他那种充满不确定性的等待场景。你必须确保伴侣提供的支持确实是支持性的，而不是与个人的需求脱节。因此，我认为明智的做法始终是进行沟通确认，尤其是当你和另一个成年人一起等待时，看看他们需要什么。现在去转移一下注意力会有帮助吗？你想聊聊吗？你想一起解决问题吗？就像我们常常忘记的那样，我们可以直接问别人我们能如何帮他们。我认为这是一个非常明智的步骤，能让对方得到他们真正需要的支持。
Now, I'm originally from New York, and I can attest to the fact that New Yorkers are notoriously impatient. Tourists work too slowly, out of towners don't know how to drive. And whenever I go back to New York, I get into that mindset. So I need to ask, is impatience contagious? Is it cultural? You know, I don't have actual hard data on this yet. But, I mean, we know there's emotion contagion for other motions, and we've clearly seen that. I would hypothesize that it is contagious and that when we see other people around us, especially if we're experiencing some arousal, but I haven't quite decided what we're feeling yet.
我本人来自纽约，我可以作证，纽约人出了名的缺乏耐心。游客动作太慢，外地人不会开车。每当我回到纽约，我就会进入那种心态。所以我必须问：缺乏耐心会传染吗？这是一种文化现象吗？你知道，我目前还没有关于此的实际硬数据。但是，我的意思是，我们知道其他情绪具有情绪传染性，这一点我们已经清晰地看到了。我假设它是会传染的，当我们看到周围的人，尤其是当我们正经历某种生理唤醒状态，但还没完全弄清楚我们究竟在感受什么时，
If we see someone else, they're tapping their fingers, fidgeting, showing all those signs of impatience, we can catch it. And that's concerning, right? Because we can create whole communities of impatience. I think culture specifically comes into play in the fact that culture sets our expectations of how life should go. And I think when I think of comparing New York to say Texas, where I live currently, when I moved to Texas, I lived in L.A. before that, it was one of the things that most struck me with this culture shift was things were slower. in Texas and that everyone wanted to chat more. And part of it, I think, is right, the crowd. The crowd's making you want to get through faster.
如果我们看到别人在敲手指、坐立不安、表现出所有缺乏耐心的迹象，我们就会被传染。这令人担忧，对吧？因为我们可以造就整个缺乏耐心的社群。我认为文化在其中具体发挥作用的地方在于，文化设定了我们对生活应该如何进行的期望。我想把纽约和德克萨斯州做个对比——我目前住在德克萨斯州。当我搬到德克萨斯州时，我之前住在洛杉矶，这种文化转变最震撼我的一点就是：德克萨斯州的生活节奏更慢，每个人都更乐意多聊聊天。部分原因，我认为，对吧，是人群。人群让你想要快点通过。
But, right, there's just a different culture of taking time and expectation of how long it should take to go through the checkout line is just different because of what that culture values. And, right, in kind of the south, you have more relational cultures, Southern hospitality, right? You see that those values show up in our approach to time and what is time. And I think maybe a place like New York City, right, our metaphor is time is that time is money. Yep.
但是，对吧，这里有一种截然不同的放慢脚步的文化，对于结账排队应该花多长时间的期望也是不同的，因为这种文化所珍视的东西不同。而且，对吧，在南方，你有更多注重人际关系的文化，南方好客之道，对吧？你会发现这些价值观体现在我们对待时间的态度以及什么是时间的观念上。我想像纽约市这样的大都市，对吧，我们的时间隐喻就是时间就是金钱。没错。
Right? It's all around the stock market and Wall Street and, right, that this is how we think about time. But our views of time definitely differ across culture significantly, not just in the U.S., but around the world. Really different views of time. linear, is it circular? Do we go by clock time or event time? That the time something's supposed to start is once everyone arrives. These are just fundamentally different views of time that are going to shape when we think too much time has passed and triggers that impatience. I've seen meditation or mindfulness mentioned as strategies to increase patients. Do those work? Yes. Yep.
对吧？这一切都围绕着股市和华尔街，对吧，这就是我们思考时间的方式。但是我们对时间的看法在不同的文化中确实存在显着差异，不仅在美国，而且在世界各地。对时间有着截然不同的看法。时间是线性的，还是循环的？我们是按钟表时间还是事件时间来过日子？某种活动应该开始的时间是当所有人都到达的时候。这些是根本上不同的时间观念，它们会塑造我们认为“时间已经过去太多”的时刻，并触发这种不耐烦。我看到有人提到冥想或正念可以作为提高耐心的策略。这些管用吗？管用。没错。
Those are effective for increasing patience. And I think part of the reason, right, we know that meditation helps you calm your own physiological system, calm your mind. And so just having the capacity to calm yourself, even through a very brief meditated practice, is really a great tool for regulation. You know, meditation also, and it's focused on especially mindfulness with non-judgment, it might allow us to sit in these moments where we're waiting with less judgment of it and more of a sense of, ah, this is just something that is and something, instead of waiting seen as something
这些对于提高耐心地说是有效的。我想部分原因在于，对吧，我们知道冥想可以帮助你平静自己的生理系统，平静心绪。因此，仅仅具备让自己平静下来的能力，即使是通过非常短暂的冥想练习，也是进行情绪调节的绝佳工具。你知道，冥想还具有，它特别关注带有非评判性质的正念，它可能允许我们在这些等待的时刻安坐下来，减少对它的评判，并怀着更多这样一种感觉：啊，这只是一种客观存在的事物，而不是把等待视为
I have to like endure and suffer, see as this is just the experience of waiting and this is part of being human. It can kind of shift. It's a minor shift, but can really help as we deal with that component of life. What caught you interested in studying patience? I started studying as a first-year grad student and positive psychology and the study of character strengths and virtues was just kind of blossoming in 2004. And as I was looking at the literature, it just struck me that all the virtues that were being studied had a very push-through, cold-directed power through it, happy flavor. And I noticed that patience was completely neglected. And it was excluded, for instance, from Seligman and Peterson's 24 virtues. They had in their values in action inventory. And I read
一种我不得不忍耐和受折磨的事情，而是把它看作是等待的体验本身，这也是身为人类的一部分。这可以带来某种转变。这是一个微小的转变，但在我们应对生活的这一部分时确实大有助益。是什么吸引你开始研究耐心的？我作为一年级研究生开始进行这方面的研究，当时在 2004 年，积极心理学以及对品格优势和美德的研究正处于蓬勃发展时期。当我查阅文献时，我突然发现，所有正在被研究的美德都带有那种强力推行、以目标为导向、充满力量感的快乐基调。而我注意到，耐心完全被忽视了。例如，它被排除在塞利格曼（Seligman）和彼得森（Peterson）的 24 种美德之外。他们把耐心列在了他们的“行动中的价值”清单里。我读了
this book. It was actually an interdisciplinary reading. I do a lot of collaboration with philosophers and theologians. And I read a book by a moral philosopher, David Bailey Hartnett argued that since the Industrial Revolution, patience has gone out of fashion that we have abandoned it as a capacity we want to cultivate in ourselves because we think the solution to waiting is technological instead of human, that we think any time we have to wait or suffer, there's a quick fix, right? We should fix it through our technology instead of recognizing that this is a deeply human concern. And that really was very compelling to me. Because if you think about the things that give meaning to life, or that are most important, they always do take time. And there's not a technological
这本书。实际上这是一次跨学科的阅读。我和哲学家、神学家有很多合作。我读了一位道德哲学家大卫·贝利·哈特（David Bentley Hart）的书，他认为自工业革命以来，耐心已经过时了，我们已经抛弃了它，不再把它当作一种我们想要在自己身上培养的能力，因为我们认为解决等待问题的办法是技术而非人类，我们认为任何我们不得不等待或受苦的时候都有一个快速修复的方案，对吧？我们应该通过我们的技术来解决它，而不是认识到这是一个深深根植于人性的问题。这对我来说真的非常有吸引力。因为如果你想想那些赋予生命意义或最重要的事情，它们确实都需要时间。而且并没有什么技术上的
solution to learning to wait for my spouse to grow in the way he's going to grow and not the way I want him to be, right? They're not, our human problems require patience. And so I just thought, oh my goodness, this is a real problem that we're not talking about this. And we're going to be unprepared when it comes to moments where we really have to wait. And I think people often do feel unprepared in those moments of deep waiting, of waiting for net breast biopsy result or waiting for these things. We have to practice it in the small things so that we can be ready to do it in the larger things. It's interesting to time it to the Industrial Revolution, because if you think about Before that, what people were doing was farming, which requires a lot of patience and waiting and plant a seed.
解决方案来学会等待我的配偶按照他自己的方式成长，而不是按照我希望他成为的样子成长，对吧？它们不是……我们人类的问题需要耐心。所以我当时就想，哦天哪，我们居然不讨论这个问题，这真是个大问题。当面临我们真正不得不等待的时刻时，我们会毫无准备。我认为人们在经历深度等待的时刻、在等待乳腺活检结果或等待这些事情时，常常确实会感到毫无准备。我们必须在小事情上练习耐心，这样才能准备好在大事上做到这一点。把这一点与工业革命联系起来很有意思，因为如果你想想在此之前，人们做的事情是农业，这需要大量的耐心、等待以及播下一颗种子。
It's going to be months and months before you see a crop. So that makes a whole lot of sense. Some of our modern societies, we've lost a sense of these rhythms of life. Right. There's a planting seed. Right. Those rhythms that you have if you're more connected to the natural environment. And so I think we maybe suffer a bit more. as humans when we get disconnected from the natural world. We have a lot of research showing that. So I think that's one of the reasons is the wisdom of timing and waiting that we need to maintain. So just to wrap up, what are you working on now?
你要经历好几个月才能看到庄稼。所以这完全说得通。在我们的某些现代社会中，我们已经失去了对这些生命节奏的感知。没错。有播种。没错。如果你与自然环境联系更紧密，你就会拥有那些节奏。所以我想我们作为人类，当我们与自然世界脱节时，可能会遭受更多的痛苦。我们有很多研究表明这一点。因此我认为这就是我们需要维持对时机和等待的智慧的原因之一。所以总结一下，你现在在研究什么？
What are your big questions that you're trying to answer? Yeah. So I have a actually next month, we start data collection looking at patients and parents of adolescents. It's going to be a four-year longitudinal study. where we look at not just kind of their self-reports, but also how other people in their lives think they are or are not patient. We also do psychophysiomeasurement in the lab and do experience sampling.
你试图回答的重大问题是什么？是的。所以实际上，下个月我们将开始收集数据，研究青少年父母的耐心。这将是一项为期四年的纵向研究，我们不仅会关注他们的自我报告，还会关注他们生活中其他人如何看待他们是否具备耐心。我们还将在实验室进行心理生理测量，并进行体验取样。
So ping them multiple times is going to be a really holistic view of these parents. And we chose to look at parents of adolescents because they are a very stressed group. When you look at parenting, I mean, everyone when they think of patients, think of parenting. anyone who's been a parent. But parents of adolescents actually show the lowest parental satisfaction and very, very high rates of stress. Because part of what you're doing there is you have less and less control, more risks to your child as well as you give out that control
所以会多次向他们发送提示，这将是对这些父母的一个非常全面的看法。我们选择研究青少年父母，是因为他们是一个压力非常大的群体。当你关注育儿时，我的意思是，每个人在想到耐心时都会想到育儿。任何当过父母的人都是如此。但青少年父母实际上表现出最低的父母满意度和非常非常高的压力水平。因为你在那里所做的事情的一部分是，你的控制力越来越少，对孩子的风险也越来越大，同时你也在放权
and have to wait for them kind of to grow. And so we wanted to look at, and we're looking at patients in adversity in particular. So looking at parents of adolescents who face particular challenges or adversities in their lives that might make patients particularly important. So, for example, we're studying parents of adolescents with developmental disabilities to see how not only they're patient with their child, but with all the health care systems they have to navigate and the school systems in ensuring that their child is taken care of.
并且必须等着它们慢慢成长。因此我们想要研究，而且我们特别在关注处于逆境中的父母。例如，我们正在研究面临特定挑战或逆境的青少年父母，这些挑战可能使父母的耐心显得尤为重要。因此，举例来说，我们正在研究患有发育障碍的青少年的父母，看看他们不仅对自己的孩子有耐心，而且在应对他们必须打交道的各个医疗保健系统以及学校系统以确保孩子得到照顾时是否也有耐心。
We're also examining patients among Muslim American parents and the unique stressors they face around maintaining their children. culture and their faith tradition in the context in the U.S. that is not always friendly to their culture or faith of a tradition and how they negotiate parenting in that context and being patient, but yet acting with courage when necessary. We're also looking at a sample of parents in Southern California who are really ethnically, socioeconomically diverse and looking at how those different components of their societal location affect their patience. across time and their well-being. So I'm really excited to dig into this particular population.
我们还在研究美国穆斯林父母中的耐心，以及他们在面对一个并不总是对他们的文化或信仰传统友好的美国社会时，在维持其子女文化和信仰传统方面所面临的独特压力，以及他们如何在那种背景下协商育龄并保持耐心，但在必要时又能表现出勇气。我们还在南加州研究了一组在种族和社会经济上都非常多元化的父母，并研究他们社会地位的不同组成部分如何影响他们随时间的耐心及其福祉。所以我非常高兴能深入研究这个特定的群体。
All right. Well, that sounds like great stuff. Well, Dr. Schnicker, I want to thank you for joining me today. Well, thank you so much for having me. I really enjoyed our conversation. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman.
好的。听起来很棒。施尼克尔博士，我要感谢您今天能来参加。非常感谢邀请我。我非常喜欢我们的对话。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并留下评论。如果您对未来的节目有任何评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学对话》由李·维纳曼制作。
Thank you for listening to the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. When the job gets tough, you need equipment that's built to handle it. The Cabota Construction lineup, featuring the versatility to do more, durability to keep going, and increased comfort for long days on the job. With skid steers, track loaders, wheel loaders, utility vehicles,
感谢您收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。当工作变得艰难时，您需要能够应对挑战的设备。久保田建筑系列产品，具有更多功能的通用性，持续运行的耐用性，以及在长时间工作时提高的舒适性。拥有滑移装载机、履带式装载机、轮式装载机、多功能车，
and the world's number one selling compact excavator for 20 years, our expanding lineup is built to deliver. Visit cabotaUSA.com or your local cabota dealer today to learn more. Go to cabotaUSA.com flash disclaimers for full disclaimers. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及连续20年全球销量第一的小型挖掘机，我们不断扩大的产品系列旨在交付成果。请立即访问 cabotaUSA.com 或您当地的久保田经销商了解更多信息。请访问 cabotaUSA.com 闪电免责声明以查看完整的免责声明。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。